hey everyone this is John rogue from
Collider I'm here with two incredibly
beautiful and talented women from the
film Brian banks with which I just
finished crying about in the bathroom
it's such an incredible film Sherri
Shepherd and Melanie live bird I hope
I'm saying that right happy thank you
thank you so it's difficult sure I want
to start with you this listen I'm used
to laughing along with you and watching
you on the shows and tell you not
hearing your points of views on things
this is such a dramatic role for you
such a strong role what is it about
taking on the fight what attracted you
to this project was it stretching on as
an actress or was it about the story of
this black man and what he had to go
through well I mean you always want to
stretch as an actress but when I saw
this script and read about this woman
named Naomi as a co-host of the view we
interviewed Bryan banks when he was
exonerated and I met Naomi Brian's
mother then but to read the script and
really see what she went through as his
mother and how much she loved him if you
meet her she's very shy yeah and she
says I'm not a hero I just love my son
but your love was what kept this man
sane during his darkest hours and to
read that what worked against me was
being a comedic actress because they
didn't want to see me for that very
reason to audition for the movie and I
had to beg and borrow and steal you know
because so many big names were being
bandied about to play Brian's mom so to
have Tom Shadia cuz you only need one
person to believe in you right Tom
Shadyac was the one because he directed
Jim Carrey an Eddie Murphy so he was
used to working with stand-up comics and
he said in my audition on FaceTime with
him he said I had to sit on Eddie and I
had to sit on Jim I'm gonna have to sit
on you but tom was able to take the
comedic side and put it on this shelf at
the fine china and bring out the side of
the
yeah because Leo McCarey sadness like a
blanket around our shoulders of what out
because she couldn't protect her son and
that they follows her to this day of not
being able to protect her son and that's
what tom was able to bring out so I'm
very thankful to him that's great to see
Melanie you've done this is us
gypsy dark matter all these and now this
one all these diamond can you get a
comedy yeah yes a few years ago I love
it I just love a challenge and this is
for me I mean this is why this is why I
do it I mean to to be given the honor of
making a movie like this with a
wonderful leader director Tom who
believed it you know he puts all through
our paces for this movie and the Quai
saying earlier some of the questions
that he used to ask my mean I think I
had five Skype interviews with him and
he'd ask me all these questions about
myself about what I was interested in
about life how I worked and I thought
why is he asking me all these questions
and then it became apparent on set and
then you know so by the time we got onto
set he knew us he knew us in a way that
was very individual and very specific to
how we worked and so it's great such a
great and interesting creative process
the whole thing and you you channel this
incredible monologue when you speak the
character speaks about your experience
with sexual assault what was it like on
the sack doing that monologue for did
all that work with Tom ahead of time
kind of oh you balls down a little bit
to let you ask definitely allows you to
be brave enough when you trust someone
as much as Tom because it's a hard it's
a hard she was a hard character to play
I mean any you know you want to do a you
know she's she's a real person
my characters based on two people but
the part of Corinna is based on someone
who is a victim of sexual assault and
she it happened to her and she wasn't
believed she was brave enough to come
forward and tell her story and no one
believed her and then she loses five
years of her life because it just eats
away at her and tears tears her apart
and there she meets Brian who's lost
five years of his life and they come
together and find this commonality
you know believing each other and and
light and hope so yes beautiful that's
the brilliance of the film sherry and
Melanie I'm like this is a tough subject
he said she said he gets exonerated but
it doesn't mean there aren't so many
cases where people speak their truth and
don't get hurt so I hope it finds an
audience share you have that great
monologue near the end when you're
trying to convince the DA to take this
on I love how you wish I loved how it
was positioned how much of that have you
been dying to do on screen or perform as
an actress oh my gosh my whole life
that's always been a secret dream of
mine to do drama but you know in
Hollywood when you know if a comedy you
get put in a box and in it like I said
it takes one person to believe in you so
you can get out of that box so it was
hard because that might come like all
time was 10:00 in the morning and I
didn't do that scene until 2:00 in the
morning
and we had gone through lunch and came
back and wardrobe change and I slept for
hours and but to have time say no this
is the scene that you're speaking for
every mother whose child has been
incarcerated you are speaking for them
it's 2:00 in the morning my stomach
growling it was it was like when I'm
like trying to remember the dream that I
had maybe he was dreaming but um he was
so brilliant and being able to get me
where I need it to be and I am a mother
of a little black boy gosh and every day
I go through that the fear of what if my
son doesn't come home and what if
somebody is looking in and in a way they
don't see the silliness and the beauty
of my child and those uncomfortable
conversations that I have to have with
him about what if the police stops you
he calls me Mommy you have to tell the
police you won't speak to your mommy
you know how horrifying that is how
scary that is so it was all of that
churning inside of me that wanted to get
out and I knew that was leo me story and
that's another mother story and that's
another mother story so that was kind of
what built it up yeah it's Joey knows
with Leo meson words that was her watch
yeah that was
those were actually Leone's words about
her son that's even more about yeah
fantastic well it's great stuff both you
do it's my pleasure to meet with both
the Kings like that is Sherri Shepherd
and Melanie library go see Brian banks
I'm telling you this one is great